et au fait tu te souviens la dernière
fois quand on regardait mal enchanteur
et que je trouvais que l'oiseau il avait
un nom bizarre mais qui m'avait dit
qu'en fait non c'était le nom d'un
chercheur antique Archimède ouais bah je
suis sur sa page wikipédia là et le mec
il est à la fois physicien astronome
mathématicien et ingénieur c'est un
couteau suisse de la science quoi tu
peux sûrement même rajouter philosophe
on est à Syracuse en moins 250 donc ça
fait clairement partie du package mais
c'est ouf quand même on en fait plus des
comme ça
ouais qu'est-ce que tu veux dire parce
que dis comme ça ça sonne un peu réacle
ce que je veux dire c'est que évidemment
on a toujours des scientifiques
aujourd'hui mais en général ils sont
spécialistes d'un truc ils sont pas à la
fois astronome mathématicien physicien
ingénieur etc ah ok en fait tu veux
parler de la pluridisciplinarité des
chercheurs c'est que c'est un vrai sujet
ça il y aurait carrément de quoi faire
une vidéo
moi je suis chaud bah écoute on est
parti bonjour à tous j'espère que vous
allez bien on est parti pour un nouvel
épisode des coulisses de la recherche en
matière de science on est passé de type
qui sont des espèces d'Iron Man des
temps antiques à faire avancer 12
domaines de recherche à la fois à
aujourd'hui des scientifiques qui
deviennent de plus en plus spécialistes
de leur discipline et même au sein même
de leur discipline il se sur spécialise
dans des trucs encore plus niches au
point que ça peut paraître carrément
bizarre aux yeux non initié toi un
exemple bah tiens par exemple en 2007 la
chercheuse japonaise Mayou Yamamoto a
gagné un prix hygénobel pour avoir
découvert que quand on porte une bouse
de vache à très haute température ça
permet d'en extraire un arôme
synthétique de vanille tu regarderas
plus jamais les corps des taux de la
même façon ok mais maintenant je me
demande comment elle a eu l'idée de
faire porter une bouse de vache à
ébullition mais effectivement c'est
plutôt spécifique comme découverte bah
plutôt oui et donc là par exemple cette
chercheuse elle est chimiste et elle
s'est ultra spécialisée dans dans les
Bousses de vache oui si on veut oui je
pensais plutôt à la synthèse chimique
des arômes mais bref il faut bien se
rendre à l'évidence que les
connaissances scientifiques se sont
incroyablement complexifiées depuis
l’époque d'Archimède et les personnes
qui sont spécialistes de plus d'une
discipline et qui en plus sont de très
bons scientifiques bah c’est quand même
assez rare oui parce que là je suis pas
en train de te parler d'un guignolo qui
aurait fait trois doctorat en trois ans
son pondre le moindre article
scientifique ou de ta belle-sœur qui a
réussi sa double licence guitare couture
à l'université de Pluton et crepins
non là je te parle de gens qui publierai
régulièrement dans des revues de premier
plan dans des disciplines différentes si
on regarde l'une des plus grandes
distinctions qui existent dans le monde
des sciences comme le prix Nobel il
n'est presque jamais arrivé qu'une même
personne décroche deux prix Nobel dans
deux disciplines différentes je dis bien
presque jamais parce qu'en fait c'est
arrivé une seule fois et c'est Marie
Curie qui obtient en 1903 le prix Nobel
de physique et en 1911 le prix Nobel de
chimie donc en plus d'être la première
fois ma recevoir un prix Nobel elle
reste la seule personne au monde à avoir
reçu deux prix Nobel pour deux
disciplines scientifiques différentes
donc GG madame Curie ouais mais bon on
est d'accord que physique chimie c'est
un peu pareil quand même non là je crois
qu'on va se faire insulter par tous les
physiciens et tous les chimistes qui
passeront par là ok je suppose qu'on
peut pinailler mais en vrai c'est un peu
pareil d'ailleurs on a bien des cours de
physique-chimie au lycée non non mais
sérieux faut que tu arrêtes là l'espace
commentaire ça va devenir une zone
d'essai pour missile nucléaire je vais
enchaîner si il est rare de trouver des
grands scientifiques pluridisciplinaires
on peut donc se demander si on va
toujours vers plus d'hyper
spécialisations où est-ce qu'on valorise
quand même des chercheurs qui auraient
une approche qui s'appuie sur plusieurs
disciplines et bien rentrons dans le vif
du sujet
alors avant toute chose il faut bien
voir que les chercheurs
pluridisciplinaires qui mélangent
plusieurs approches scientifiques ça
existe bien mais je vais vous montrer
que le monde de la recherche est
organisé de telle façon qu'il
parviennent rarement à faire carrière et
à s’insérer convenablement dans le champ
scientifique je m'appuie ici sur un
article de 2022 écrit par quatre
coauteurs dans Organisation science et
qu'on pourrait traduire par une nouvelle
vision de l'impératif catégorique
gardien du temple maintien des
frontières et pénalités d'évaluation
dans la science les auteurs ont
travaillé sur des données italiennes
pour essayer de voir comment se
positionne les chercheurs qui ont une
approche pluridisciplinaire dans le
monde académique
[Musique]
alors la littérature très existante sur
le sujet montrer déjà que les
scientifiques pluridisciplinaires sont
en général pénalisées dans leur
avancement de carrière mais déjà là je
comprends pas pourquoi c'est pas plus
valorisé au contraire ça devrait plutôt
être une bonne chose d'avoir plusieurs
cordes à son arc elle a justement pas
vraiment parce que en général les
évaluateurs qui sont importants pour la
publication mais aussi pour les
recrutements ils appartiennent à une
seule discipline et ils ont du mal à se
faire une idée des compétences et de la
fiabilité dans le candidat s'il fait
appel à des méthodes qu'il ne maîtrise
pas trop ah ouais d'accord du coup si je
prends un exemple ça fait que un
chercheur qui ferait à moitié de la
physique quantique et à moitié de la
linguistique il serait évalué soit par
des physiciens soit par des linguistes
et ils auraient chacun du mal à évaluer
la partition scientifique dont ils ont
pas spécialistes alors oui c'est l'idée
générale sauf que là à moins qu'on
découvre que les particules élémentaires
se mettent à parler espéranto quand
elles sont dans un état intriqué j'ai du
mal à saisir la pertinence de cette
double approche cela dit ces inquiétudes
qu'on comprend bien sur la qualité du
travail d'un chercheur pluridisc devrait
normalement se dissiper quand on est
face à un candidat sur lequel on a
beaucoup d'informations et qui a un
super parcours universitaire en gros
quelqu'un qui a beaucoup publié et qui
est reconnu par ses pairs dans les deux
disciplines et ben justement on observe
précisément l'inverse c'est-à-dire et
bien l'étude porte sur le recrutement à
un poste de professeur dans une
université italienne et les chercheurs
ont passé en revue les
55497 candidatures qui ont été soumises
à 164 jury différents et à chaque fois
ce sont des juristes spécifiques à une
discipline et ce qu'on voit pour les
chercheurs pluridisciplinaires c'est que
plus ils sont performants c'est-à-dire
plus ils ont de publications et de
citations et moins ils sont susceptibles
d'être recrutés attention que je
comprenne bien tu es en train de me dire
que plus un chercheur est bon plus il
est pénalisé ça a pas de sens et
pourtant c'est ce qui ressort très
clairement et les faits il est mastock
parce que la pénalité à un candidat
pluridisciplinaire très performant elle
est supérieure de plus de 50% à celle
qui appliquait un candidat plus
redisciplinaire peu performant attends
mais c'est ouf comment ils expliquent ça
alors je vais pas détailler toute
l'étude elle fait une vingtaine de pages
et elle est en libre accès je mettrai
bien sûr le lien dans la description si
vous voulez une version plus digeste les
auteurs ont par la suite écrit une
tribune dans Le Monde pour alerter sur
ce phénomène le titre de la tribune des
assez efficace c'est plus un chercheur
pluridisciplinaire et performant moins
il est susceptible d'être accrédité par
cette terre évidemment je mettrai aussi
la tribune du Monde dans la description
[Musique]
bon les chercheurs font quand même des
hypothèses pour essayer de comprendre
pourquoi on discrimine plutôt les bons
chercheurs pluridisciplinaires et ils
pensent que c'est pour maintenir le
statu quo de la discipline et là tu vas
me demander pourquoi recruter un bon
chercheur pluridisciplinaire ça
viendrait disrupter le statu quo des
disciplines non ce que je comprends pas
c'est plutôt pourquoi recruter un bon
chercheur pluridisciplinaire ça
viendrait disrupter le statut quo des
disciplines bah oui c'est ce que je te
dis que pour comprendre ça il faut bien
comprendre comment est organisé le monde
scientifique avec des laboratoires des
facultés des départements qui ont chacun
des modes de fonctionnement différents
des équipes d'évaluateurs différentes et
surtout des financements bien distincts
ah oui attends je crois que j'ai compris
en fait les chercheurs
pluridisciplinaires c'est un peu le
bordel parce que ils sont un cheval sur
deux labos donc on sait jamais vraiment
qui doit les financer en plus c'est plus
difficile d'évaluer leur travail s'ils
utilisent des méthodes un peu atypiques
ouais mais ça ça nous explique toujours
pas pourquoi c'est les bons chercheurs
qui se font le plus discriminés
justement j'y viens ce qu'il faut avoir
en tête c'est que dans le monde
universitaire on a en fait un tout petit
nombre de gens très talentueux et
productifs qui vont exercer une
influence disproportionnée sur l'avenir
de leur discipline ils peuvent décider
notamment des domaines de recherche
prioritaire ou de l'orientation vers de
nouvelles approches de nouvelles
théories ou de nouvelles méthodes on
peut prendre l'exemple de la sociologie
la sociologie française actuelle à
l'université ne serait probablement pas
la même aujourd'hui si Bourdieu n'avait
pas existé il est le tout premier
sociologue à obtenir la médaille d'or du
CNRS il a été professeur au Collège de
France il a fondé une revue qui encore
aujourd'hui très prestigieuse bref il a
marqué sa discipline du coup pour en
revenir au recrutement il faut bien se
mettre dans la tête des jurys quand il
recrute un super bon chercheur ce qui se
dit c'est que ils sont potentiellement
en train de recruter le nouveau Pierre
Bourdieu de leur discipline ou à tout le
moins quelqu'un qui va avoir de
l'influence dans le sens scientifique
c'est pour ça que recruter un chercheur
pluridisciplinaire très ça peut menacer
le statut quo des disciplines parce que
il va peut-être je sais pas fusionner
des labos ou des sources de financement
ou ouvrir des sons de recherche ou les
anciens ne sont pas vraiment compétents
alors qu'à l'inverse un collègue
pluridisciplinaire dont le CV n'est pas
particulièrement remarquable il paraît
plus inoffensif et du coup bah il subit
moins la pénalité au moment du
recrutement ah bah merde en fait les
mecs ont juste peur que si ils recrutent
quelqu'un de trop bon leur petit
département et leur petite méthode
confortables soient complètement
bouleversée par des programmes de
recherche innovants et du coup ils
préfèrent torpiller les potentiels
innovateurs latence ça ça va pas du tout
dans le sens d'une meilleure science et
de meilleure connaissance scientifiques
et non mais il faut bien avoir en tête
que la science elle est avant tout faite
par des humains qui ne sont pas des purs
esprits tournés vers la vérité mais
qu'ils ont eux aussi des intérêts des
biais et des habitudes et que ça ça
influence assez largement les
découvertes scientifiques c'est
notamment ce que montrer le sociologue
Bruno Latour qui vient malheureusement
de nous quitter ce 9 octobre 2022 dans
un de ces livres les plus célèbres la
vie de laboratoire écrit avec le
sociologue des sciences Steve o'glar en
1979 ils ont fait une étude ethnologique
dans un laboratoire de recherche
spécialisé en euros endocrinologie et il
montre justement que la science elle
fonctionne pas du tout comme on peut se
représenter naïvement là méthode
scientifique avec des gros guillemets
mais qu'au contraire les objets d'études
scientifiques ils sont socialement
construits dans les laboratoires au
cours des interactions humaines en fait
comment on vient de le voir la science
elle s'appuie sur des institutions
humaines des universités des
laboratoires qui définissent elles-mêmes
des frontières entre les disciplines qui
peuvent paraître arbitraire à un œil
extérieur mais qui produisent des effets
sur le type de science qui est produite
non mais ça ça a l'air intéressant là ce
qui raconte Bruno Latour on peut pas
développer un peu plus ou là tu es
ambitieux parce que Bruno Latour c'est
un gros morceau mais ce suit justement
en train de préparer une petite vidéo
spéciale pour essayer d'en parler un peu
plus longuement parce que il a fait
beaucoup de choses dans sa vie et
d'ailleurs on est en train de parler de
pluridisciplinarité il cumulé déjà pas
mal de casquettes sociologue
anthropologue théologien philosophe des
sciences mais clairement on en reparlera
une autre fois bon ok j'attendrai
jusqu'à l'épisode spécial mais tu as
intérêt à le sortir avant la prochaine
décennie
[Musique]
bon tout ça pour dire que la
pluridisciplinarité en sciences c'est
pas si facile que ça à mettre en place
outre le fait que dès qu'on rentre dans
le supérieur on a de moins en moins de
se dire pluridisciplinaire on voit que
les structures et les acteurs de ces
filières ont un intérêt pour leur
carrière à conserver le statu quo et les
frontières entre chaque discipline du
coup les chercheurs qui pourraient
donner un petit coup de pied dans la
fourmilière ce hurt à un plafond de
verre et en particulier les chercheurs
les plus brillants et productifs ont du
mal à accéder au poste qui leur
permettrait d'avoir vraiment de
l'influence sur les trajectoires des
projets de recherche alors des solutions
serait quand même envisageable et les
auteurs de la tribune proposent par
exemple une diversification du profil
des jurys ou de mettre en place une
discrimination positive envers les
profils pluridisciplinaires je vous
laisse lire la tribune du Monde pour
plus de détails alors une question que
je me suis moi-même posée en lisant
l'article c'est si on trouvait le
problème dans les mêmes proportions au
sein des sciences humaines et sociales
parce que intuitivement il me semble
qu'il y a quand même plus de
pluridisciplinarité au sein des SHS que
dans d'autres disciplines à la fois dans
la manière de les enseigner que dans la
diversité des méthodes qui sont
mobilisées mais ça ce sera le sujet de
la prochaine vidéo
[Musique]
cette vidéo des coulisses de la
recherche est maintenant terminée
j'espère qu'elle vous aura plu n'hésitez
pas à mettre un pouce vers le haut et
surtout à la partager c'est super
important de partager abonnez-vous à la
chaîne socialogique si c'est pas déjà
fait c'est gratuit et comme ça vous
manquerez pas la vidéo suivante sur la
pluridisciplinarité en sciences humaines
qui sortira très bientôt sur la chaîne
je vous le promets je vous fais des gros
bisous et je vous dis à très vite Ciao
[Musique]